[Music]
Jim whatever I do I do it to protect you
see you understand I understand
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna go here
our rebellion is all that remains to
push back the Empire
I think you might be able to help us
when was the last time you were in
contact with your father what is this
it appears he is critical to the
development of a super weapon
if my father built this thing we need to
find him all right how many do I need
they are requesting a callsign need some
rogue wrote one that we are dealing with
here
immeasurable
if the Empire has this kind of power
what chance do we have we have hope
rebellions are built on hope
no idea we're coming
take hold of this moment the force is
strong
make ten men feel like a hundred
take the next chance
rebels on you
[Music]
[Music]
it's like the fantasy you always have
the kids everywhere is an amazing sharp
amazing character
it's about the humanity of it which just
makes the whole thing so real ready I
try
your hearts beating and you're actually
in this situation you get something very
genuine that you can the plant you'll
actually compose shots that if we were
on a green screen set you just wouldn't
have known we're available fresh is so
high we're making a film that's right
touching my favorite movie of all time
but then if you're too respectful of it
that you didn't do anything new or
different take a risk then what are you
bringing to the table
kill stand down there
[Music]
I mean this is really where a film crew
like this really comes into their
about kids when you were four years old
I grew up with Star Wars figures it's a
bit like just being that kid again
may the force be with us
[Music]
the world is coming undone Imperial
flags rain across the galaxy
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
with a mission for you
[Music]
a major weapons test is imminent we need
to know how to destroy
if you're really doing this I want to
help good
good
I've been recruiting for the rebellion
for a long time we destroyed outside the
Empire now
I fear nothing all is as the force will
see
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
Thanks there is a much time
every day they grow stronger
there was a ninety-seven point six
percent chance of failure
it means well
this is a chance
[Music]
are you with me
all the way
[Music]
this is a rebellion isn't it I rebelled
if you continue to fight what will you
become
rogue one a Star Wars story on Cinemark
XD screens the world is coming undone
Imperial flags rain across the galaxy we
have intercepted a coded Imperial
transmission it indicates that a major
weapons test is imminent the message was
sent by your father we need to know what
it is and how to destroy it
this is our chance to make a real
difference if you're really doing this I
want to help
good I've been recruiting for the
rebellion for a long time would you join
our hope we fight the unfired I fear
nothing
all this as the horse wilted every day
they grow stronger
what will you do
when they catch you
you do agree q if you continue to fight
what will you become
are you with me all the way
may the force be with us
you
state your name for the record
Jen also forgery of Imperial documents
possession of stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest on
your own from the age of 15 reckless
aggressive and undisciplined this is a
rebellion isn't it IRA bail we have a
mission for you a major weapons test is
imminent - we need to know what it is
how to destroy it is that clear yes sir
what will you do when they catch you
will you do a Greek you
if you continue to fight
what will you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
I needed to me time and I came to
Australia
that's when I moved in with Daryl hello
and here we are you know it's a nice
flat